oh hello uh hi everyone sorry uh we had
some technical issues here with uh pcs
uh deciding not to
cooperate um but anyway uh thanks for
calling in and um i'll talk to you about
work that we're doing on post
genome-wide association
analysis so
to begin with i thought i would
talk a little bit about the spectrum of
disease
development
as an example a well-known one colon
cancer we know results from
many different
aberrations that occur at different
stages
starting with germline changes
in some
subset of
cancers the most
well-known is the apc gene mutations on
chromosome 5q that lead to
polyp development
but also mutations in
mismatch repair contribute to cancer
development as well
and then there's a multiple
steps in carcinogenesis that occur with
multiple additional mutations
so
we we know that germline susceptibility
as well as
additional mutations uh promote cancer
development
so therefore there's interest in the
whole spectrum we have been most
interested in germline susceptibility
this identifies
early
those individuals in whom
early interventions would be useful and
also
provides information about the early
steps in
disease development
so next slide
so
in terms of trying to find genetic
factors that
influence disease susceptibility there
are
sorry i need to turn my sound down a
little bit
there's really three different
approaches that have been taken
initially we use linkage analysis
methods in which we
studied
extended families with multiple affected
individuals
this approach is very effective in
identifying high-risk genetic factors
but
those
family studies are quite difficult to do
um and
um
there
this approach will only find genetic
factors that have a very strong impact
on disease so these are
important but relatively
uncommon
conditions
more recently we've used genome-wide
association studies and these approaches
sort of go after the opposite spectrum
more common
causes of disease
that typically have very low impact on
risk and
last we're moving into a next generation
sequencing approach which will
identify all the genetic factors
predisposing to disease but have the
problem of
relatively higher error rates and much
more expensive
costs so some
attention needs to be applied to the
design of these studies which i'll talk
about later in the talk so um in this
slide i'm just showing you a kind of a
summary of a continuation of variation
and susceptibility this is a nice paper
by chung at all so
linkage analysis works well for the high
risk conditions that are relatively
uncommon association mapping works very
well for
genes that have low effect
and are more common and what we haven't
been able to deal with very well in the
past was
those
relatively
more common
conditions that have moderate effects
and we're hoping that sequencing
approaches will
help to fill in this area
so
for genome-wide association studies
which i'll talk about
for a bit here
single nucleotide polymorphisms have
been very effective
in the mapping they're they're these are
common polymorphisms
their
allele frequency
varies
between zero and a half with
more of the variance being relatively
uncommon just due to drift but also
probably related to selection against
some variants that
may be slightly deleterious
almost very few of the single
nucleotide polymorphisms are directly
associated with disease they
typically tag variation
and so are used as road maps to identify
uh genetic conditions and and there the
problem is that we
since they don't directly uh typically
associate with disease risk uh trying to
identify
whether they're related or what other
variation is related becomes a challenge
so what we really would like to do is
identify all the causal variants
and that is
the challenge of this reverse genetic
approach so
goals of our genomic studies are to
identify
the pathogenesis of complex diseases
like cancer develop strategies for
characterizing individual risk
which could improve early diagnosis and
screening and to develop new strategies
for prevention and treatment
so as examples i'm going to use studies
that we've
undertaken for lung cancer
here's a typical design that we used
where we had a genome-wide association
study with at that time 300 000 um snips
that were located along the genome
and
provide a kind of a road map these days
we're up to two to five million snips
per experiment
um still this is much less than the
three billion base pairs that occur in
in in the whole genome
but we would
use
this kind of approach in
a large collection of individuals but
still
couldn't afford to do to genotype every
single person so typically skim off the
most significant
variations and confirm them in
subsequent studies
and then at the end of the day do more
detailed studies to identify gene
environment interactions and
study subsets so
this slide is
showing you
an example of what we had done so
i lead a consortium that is
integrating genome-wide association
studies from
multiple lung cancer
case control analyses
and at this point we have results from
about 15 000 cases and 30 000 controls
and that's shown in the lower panel
that's including all cases and controls
in the upper panel um
we're showing the i'm sorry the lower
panels all ever smokers the upper panel
is showing you the never smokers for
lung cancer
in the bottom panel you can see as you
look along the
the x-axis which is the chromosomal
positions
and the y-axis is showing you the minus
log p-values so
the larger
the minus log p value the more
significant the result is
so you can see that forever smokers
there are some very very strong signals
especially on chromosome 15q where there
are some nicotinic acetylcholine
receptors but also there are some other
signals
for the never smokers at this point
there's really no
significant findings
the reason for that is somewhat unclear
one part of the answer is the sample
size is smaller but also
it's possible that lung cancer in never
smokers is a more heterogeneous disease
than in ever smokers so
so far you know genome-wide studies have
been very
effective at identifying very very
significant associations between disease
susceptibility and
genetic factors
but
the problem has been that still they
don't explain
that much of the
disease associations in terms of
absolute risks
the impact of
genome-wide association studies has been
very high with many many
high-impact
papers being published and they have
provided new insights into the etiology
of many different diseases but
you know there's been an ongoing concern
that these approaches don't explain as
much of the variability among
individuals as was expected so many
studies of
you know familial aggregation of disease
identified strong heritability for some
conditions
like for instance smoking behavior which
shows something like
60 to 70 percent
evidence for genetic component
and yet the actual explained variability
is quite low so the question is you know
why are we
not doing better than we have expected
to do in terms of doing genome-wide
association studies so some of the
reasons are we don't have enough markers
perhaps the genome-wide association
markers that were chosen are incomplete
they don't characterize very well
regions with copy number changes
they can't do an adequate job of
characterizing inter individual
variability when there are
micro satellites you know
markers or regions that are
repetitive
and another possibility is that
the premise upon which this approach was
proposed the common disease common
variant hypothesis is inadequate
that hypothesis was that common diseases
would be caused by multiple common
variants but
there's some evidence that
many common diseases might be caused by
an aggregation of
common and rare variants also perhaps
epigenetics plays more of a role than
we'd anticipated and last
concern is ideological heterogeneity
so
i'm seeing copy number variants are a
problem they're not well characterized
on genome-wide scan
platforms
i won't talk about that too much so in
terms of
heterogeneity i thought i would show you
this
slide from a recent paper
by timofeva and others
showing
variation in associations according to
the subtypes of lung cancer so
you can see that
compared to the first sort of manhattan
plot i showed
which was for all ever smokers
and never smokers in this
plot there's a
quite a difference according to the
histological subtype so the squamous
cell carcinomas are showing more
findings both all of the results show
some
findings for the nicotinic acetylcholine
receptor region on 15q but
the squamous cell carcinomas are showing
signals on chromosomes 6 and 12 and
chromosome 9 and additional different
findings on chromosome 5
whereas adenocarcinoma just really shows
a significant result on 5. so
the heterogeneity
within the group called lung cancer
causes us to lose some power to be able
to identify
genetic findings and so there's a strong
need to to
as well as possible characterize the uh
the um the condition that you're
studying in the case of lung cancer we
can
do a reasonably good job of that using
histological
findings although we might do better if
we could do expression studies or other
kinds of approaches on the disease
phenotype to even further subclassify
that
for lung cancer it's a bit of a problem
because
not all lung cancers are resected but
this might be feasible for
other
kinds of conditions that can be
subdivided
so
let's see
for sporadic lung cancer there's there's
a couple different genes that are
involved
on chromosome 5 the h tert and clptm1l
genes which i will talk about later
and again there were there was marked
heterogeneity in the associations
for one
variant that's very close to
the tert gene
um which is telomerase there there was
association for multiple different um
subtypes whereas
a marker near clptm1l was mostly
associated with squamous carcinoma so
again even within narrow regions there
is heterogeneity by
subsets
again going back to the common disease
variant hypothesis being perhaps
inadequate
in the presence of some selection
we would accept expect that disease
associated alleles will become uncommon
and the usual genome-wide association
platforms that we
have used were chosen to have
an over-representation of more common
alleles
this is because the common alleles
are informative about
wide areas near them
and they were thought to be more
useful but
um that's not true if you're interested
in rare alleles so
there's a bit of a challenge there that
the newer platforms
such as
exome genotyping arrays or
even some of the five million um snip
markers do include multiple uh markers
with rear alleles so they provide a
better view
um they were more expensive than the
older versions with fewer markers
so um
let's see
in
in ever smokers there's a very strong
effect on chromosome five so we'll talk
about that in a minute
so sorry chromosome 15. so chromosome 15
has this nicotinic acetylcholine
receptor region
and we
have gone back into that region and
performed sequencing of
the exons that
of the genes that underlie this region
and for example for the chrna5
gene that is
in the region when we sequenced just 96
people we found
many many different variants and some of
these have strong impacts on the
function some of them were stop
mutations
others uh change uh proteins uh from
hydrophobic to hydrophilic
type of uh amino acids so uh that would
have an impact um so there there seems
to be aside from the common uh variants
many
rare variants that are also influencing
susceptibility and
so that raises the um
the
concern that there may be
even for common diseases like lung
cancer there may be many different
rare variants
contributing along with the common ones
and so we we had proposed that
slightly deleterious snips
are
influencing the risk for disease
their effects are not strong enough for
selection to eliminate them
but
they still contribute to disease
susceptibility and if you actually look
at the
distribution of
minor allele frequencies in the
population versus their
predicted impact on
on
disease risk or phenotypes you see that
with multiple different measures you
see that the
less common um
variants are more likely to have an
impact on
on the phenotypes so on the left hand
side
we're showing
the results from applying a software
package called polyphen which
uses a compost a composite score of the
impact of a snip on
protein function
and that is showing that the less common
allele variants with less common alleles
typically have a stronger impact on
on
the effect of
changing the protein and on the right
hand side is a measure of evolutionary
conservation again showing that
snips with the rare alleles tend to have
a
stronger association with
not being in conserved regions so sorry
of being inc
less common alleles are more likely to
be in conserved regions and um
and to be expected to be deleterious
um and same is true here looking at
protein fault folding parameters so
less common alleles may have a stronger
impact
so
the thought is that
you know part of the reason why we
haven't found as much through gus is
that rare variants may be contributing
more than we can characterize very well
with
the
g watts approaches that had been applied
to date
so how could you do a better job with a
gui study then as i was saying the newer
panels include many more snips and rarer
ones
we now have the
1000 genomes project which allows us to
infer
genotypes more effectively and so
identify
the variants that are contributing
and we do have some examples where this
has identified
less common variants with stronger
impact on disease risk so it this
approach does work to some extent
again we need big sample sizes to
identify the impact of rare variants and
that's a challenge
the in order to genotype large numbers
of people
we
have to come up with cost-effective
strategies and
sort of a hybrid approach where we do
some um genotyping with a genome-wide
association type platforms and
additional analysis using sequencing is
a reasonable approach to
be able to leverage the
increased information from sequencing
with the decreased cost of genotyping
so there there are some software
approaches
here i put this weight approach that
uploads the rare variants
there's also
newer approaches for uh analyzing rare
variants that that can be applied and uh
last
in the game on approach uh this is a
consortium that um
i'm a co-leader of we've been able to uh
leverage collaborations to to develop a
very inexpensive
genotyping platform in this example
we're able to do uh analyze 600 000
variants
for a cost of 40 dollars a sample so
that's a very
reasonable way to
be able to analyze large numbers of
people
and here i am just showing you one
example we're just finishing a study and
we
use the thousand genomes
to infer
genotypes and then look at some rare
variants and one of the variants that we
identified has about
a
1.7 fold
effect on risk and there are some some
subtypes with very strong impacts on
risk from this variant
variant has about a half a percent um
allele frequency and so it's missed uh
without the um imputation that we did so
now turning to the
other middle range here where we're
trying to identify moderate effect genes
that
are
also moderately rare sequencing studies
are
probably going to be very effective
and we're just entering the era in which
sequencing
comes with reasonable cost so the
problem with sequencing is the cost
and one way to
deal with that is to seek more
informative samples in this
set of slides i was i'm talking about
trying to improve the ability to
identify
less common variants that have moderate
impact on risk and there's a paper we
published in 2010
looking at
sampling cases based on family history
so
in this slide we're
talking about the
number of individuals needed to
detect
an effect according to the sampling
approach and
the first
bar here with 985
individuals required was if we just
sampled cases and controls the next
panel is showing you if you sampled
cases and that had an affected sibling
and controls you would only need about a
fourth as many
individuals and here a few sample
cases that have two affected siblings
versus controls you would need something
like an eighth as many people
so
oversampling cases that have affected
relatives can greatly decrease the
number of individuals that you have to
analyze
whether it's a genome-wide association
study or sequencing in particular for
sequencing
family studies are important so um
that's sort of the design here
um sorry i'm having trouble with the
internet now
i mean i lost my internet connection let
me go back in
just hold on a second
okay
um right i'm back in
um so now uh just to talk about uh what
we're doing for uh post genome-wide
association studies um
we're
we have a project uh funded by nih which
has sort of three components one is the
discovery phase
another is follow-up biological analyses
and last is epidemiological
characterization so we've sort of been
talking about the discovery phase
but next
we would be interested in
the biological and epidemiological
studies so this is kind of the design of
our
of our
application and
we're interested in collaborating with
other investigators and involving them
basically um there are five different
disease sites
involved
and each within
to form a a matrix kind of structure
there are
committees that
that cross across the different uh
disease sites um
the
more active ones are the epidemiological
and clinical and analytical and risk
modeling and
functional assays and epigenetics is
beginning now
so
as an example the clinical and epi
working group
performs multiple different cross-site
studies and and this is an area where
other investigators could
are welcome to join in we've
developed a virtual pathology network
and
an inventory that identifies for
other investigators
which groups have samples that could be
shared
and we've also been involved in
data harmonization across sites to make
it feasible for the different groups to
collaborate
there's an analytical and risk modeling
group that
you know develops approach new
approaches there's a gene environment
group for example
so again i mentioned about the sporadic
lung cancer and
heterogeneity in association with
squamous carcinomas being
related to clptm1l
and all cancers related to the
telomerase region
so
one of the approaches that we took in
this consortium is to
study
the relevance of
the
clptm1l gene on
tumor development and what was done in
this study published by michael james
was a knockdown of
clptm1l versus
the telomerase gene
in this finding in this study they found
that when they knocked down using a
short hairpin
rna approach
clptm1l they had a
great impact on the growth of
tumors in the mouse model so showing
that
this novel clp tm1l gene was
related to
growth of tumors and control of
apoptosis
also the this clppm1l had
relevance to
the response to genotoxicity so
this was one approach to try and
separate out the problem with the g wasp
type study and also sequencing to some
extent is that you identify genetic
variants and you don't necessarily know
what their relevance is
to disease causation
here we are able to
show that
actually some of the variation in
tumor growth in the chromosome 5 region
had to do with clp tm1l and not just to
telomerase both of them are candidates
so now i wanted to briefly talk about
another area of interest for
lung cancer so
the main risk factor for lung cancer is
smoking
smoking itself is the kind of a complex
behavior and
the major steps include initiation
and then
cigarette use which leads to nicotine
dependence and then finally many most
people eventually quit but it may take
years for them to get to that point
where they're able to do that
and these are some slides given to me by
laura bairud
so again
chromosome 15q i mentioned was very
important for
lung cancer but
it has overwhelming effect for uh
smoking behavior um so it's really the
the major finding um was again these
nicotinic receptors on chromosome 15 for
smoking and there really wasn't that
much else found
again i mentioned that the heritability
of smoking is 60 to 70 percent but
the actual
amount of
variability explained by these receptors
on chromosome 15 is quite low it's only
a few percent
so this is an ongoing question why it's
a little explained by smoking behavior
again part of it has to do with
with the genetic architecture and part
of it has to do with uh smoking itself
that
we thought this was a relatively easy
thing to measure but it turns out that
people's smoking behavior is actually
quite complicated
and the amount that they report versus
the actual amount of
intake varies according to
the the genes on chromosome 15 as well
if you look at nicotine metabolism but
uh one of the other findings uh from
chennai doll and and laura baird's group
was that um these genes play us a major
impact on smoking cessation so if you
look um
overall
there's
not so much effect on
on chromosome 5 there's a bit of an
effect
for smoking cessation
there's about a four year difference in
when people can quit according to the
genotypes
that they have
what was surprising in this study was
that
this was from a clinical trial that was
performed so when they looked at the
overall population there was a small
effect but not that dramatic
however when they stratified
into
placebo versus treatment they saw a
dramatic impact
for individuals that had
variants that put them at high risk
for developing
lung cancer or
for being dependent
and
particularly so there was less of an
impact in the treated group
and further analysis of this
finding showed that
individuals with two alleles that again
put them at higher risk for lung cancer
and being dependent
benefited
from the intervention
so these were pharmacological
interventions whereas people that didn't
have either of the high risk variants
had no benefit from the
the intervention so this is a very
strong kind of gene environment
interaction
so that's shown on these next slides
so um
i think i'll go quickly through this you
can look at these
so i i think
in conclusion the genome wide studies
have been very productive in identifying
a genetic architecture of common
influences for complex diseases
evaluating the actual functional effects
of identified variants can be
challenging
relatively few variants have been
identified that are causal
this
this region on chromosome 15q i've been
talking about does have
a causal variant and
there's also some variants
upstream of the promoter of
nicotinic receptor alpha 5 and alpha 3
that
influence expression level so this is
kind of an example where we do have some
causal variants even though we have a
couple causal variants there seem to be
many more that
are
lying within this region and these
additional variants
can probably contribute to disease but
are harder to characterize without very
large studies
so follow-up studies
have identified significant effects of
genetic loci on on cancer development by
integrating data across multiple groups
and genetic loci identified by g west
studies do provide insights for
cancer prevention they provide novel
targets for
for
discussion about
therapies
and sequencing is useful
it's expensive and therefore
some sort of targeting is appropriate
whether it's identifying subsets that
are
most informative
or
choosing regions that have been
identified from genome-wide studies or
from linkage studies
upon which we can
do a
more sequencing of
more individuals
those are sort of the approaches so um
and i wanted to thank
all my colleagues laura by roots groups
been very helpful ivan gorloff has
contributed to understanding the
effective alleles on disease risk
and uh
there's a group at iarc that's been very
involved um and then my local group here
uh young honda kai zoo and wei chen
so um i think that's all for now i'm
sorry we had trouble with the
setup and i think i can take some
questions uh now
let's see what they were
no questions
any
okay well i went quickly you know there
are
some follow-ups here we we are um trying
to
consider uh development of
uh clinical trials that would be
conditional on genotyping
for smoking behavior for example
it's a kind of a complicated
to to address that kind of approach
if you want to
design a trial that's conditional on
on genotypes then you have to have an
approach for
rapidly
genotyping and allocating individuals
and
those kinds of designs are sort of under
development
okay
any other
i'm happy to take questions if there
aren't
probably went a little fast
this
oh now i have a picture
oh okay i see something here speaking of
to us publishing in high impact journal
for
eg nature genetics i'm worried by the
fact whereby there's not much novelty in
those publications except different
populations different diseases
larger sample size worse still there
are not much functional study on those
snips identified
um well i i think it's a bit early
there
uh
there are you know we are trying to do
functional studies i think the problem
is the time frame um between when one
observes a
novel association and then uh trying to
characterize exactly what that
association is doing
the timelines are quite different so
for example
in this study i was describing where we
had identified
variation in chromosome 5
where there are
associations between lung cancer risk
and
telomerase
the h10 gene
and clptm1l
we
already had animal models that
were
you know for
for h tert
but not so much for clp tm1l so we had
to have a an approach for um
for modulating
um
clptm1l
and that takes quite a long time so um
there's kind of a lag of
at least a year
typically between when you find a
variant and when it can when its impact
can be understood we are trying to close
that gap
but um you know that's not easy to do i
i would say that um one of the
sort of areas where i think
we might benefit more is by having a
broader range of
model systems so
in our consortium we have uh
cell model systems and um
and animal models but we're lacking uh
yeast and um and some of the zebrafish
and and that sort of thing so um
you know a broader integration between
the um the population-based groups and
some of the animal modeling group the
different model organisms groups would
be
helpful to everyone i think
i i will say too that you know
sequencing
um also does identify new variants and
where it's worked really well has been
in
so far in family studies where there are
very very well characterized phenotypes
that were difficult to
to
previously identify causal mutations for
so in some cases those have been
very effective in identifying
new
new new causal
factors
but
trying to extend that to sort of more
common diseases is is challenging
and it will and that will again require
a tight collaboration between the uh
the population-based researchers in the
in the modeling groups
oh
okay the next question
signal detection theory receiver
operating characteristics applications
the gus snip analyses
so
these have worked
variably depending on the disease i
would say so
for some diseases
particularly some of the autoimmune
diseases
the
ability to identify individuals at high
enough risks
to make it useful at an individual level
to apply genetic
results for
for identifying very high risk
individuals that's worked better
for cancer it hasn't worked as well yet
and again it depends a little bit on the
cancer so for prostate cancer we're up
to something like 75 or 80 different
snips that influence risk
the overall ability to classify
individuals
is
currently higher from g wasp studies
than it is from
something like psa so
at this point the snips
are becoming adequate for individual
characterization
for other diseases
like lung cancer right now we we can't
really very well at an individual level
on characterized risk and so the
question is
you know why does it work better for
some diseases than others
one possibility for
diseases like the autoimmune ones is
that
perhaps there's been some selection for
alleles that um
that protect against
infections
but at the same time may increase risk
for some autoimmune conditions so that
the common snips are
more informative about risk for some
autoimmune conditions
for cancers
again there may be mild selection
against
the snips that influence risk and so
it's harder to from a g watts type
approach to identify
enough of the variability to
adequately predict
risk from from the g wasps it could be
that as we get more
you know denser snips and we get better
at impu imputing that will do a better
job of
pulling out the snips and identifying
risk
the other point is that so far we've
been doing individual snip versus
disease and that's
perhaps not as informative as
it could be if there are
you know gene gene interactions or
pathways contributing to risk so
you know
it it's variable how well this has
worked again it works better for
autoimmune diseases
and not so well for
some of the more common diseases
so what do you think of do you
what do you think of g wasps can be used
for finding out predis's
predisposition genes for cancer so um
these have been quite informative
for um
first identifying some of the genes that
are influencing disease risk so um for
instance the uh
h2 region on chromosome 5 has shown up
in multiple different cancers
and results are
a little bit confusing actually they
they show that there are some
effects directly on telomere lengths but
there also seem to be other effects and
the
relevance
to each cancer type vary so for some
cancers
the chromosome 5 markers are protective
um others
they're
risk factors so um
again it takes time between when you
identify the association and when you
can um understand its its relevance
in prostate cancer there there have been
some novel associations
associated with
the functional
impact
on um
on
biomarkers there's one uh snip that
influences um
uh expression of psa and so that um
that that has a relevance to
understanding the the biology of
prostate cancer
so
anyway
melvin bernstein
okay well um i i guess that's all the
questions uh
um thank you for joining i'm sorry i i
end up talking a little bit too fast
perhaps but um anyway
okay thank you